une tasse de taureau est ce que c'est
une blague hilarante et censé mieux
faire rire c'est nous les chevaux qui
avons de belles jambes fait pour
l'attendre l'aideront des pas de côté
grossière la regardez moi cette bouffée
strudel phase de bâtons de colle blanche
entre le tombé ils ont raison c'est vrai
comment un gros taureau maladroit
pourrait faire ça baiser mon petit gars
comment ibos oies et s'appuie sur la
danse marine cette latence 3 contre 1
c'est pas très équitable sa nouvelle
patronne de mu
venez vous s'adresse ligne aile bonne de
boulin réjouissent pas trop vite
rumsteck saison autant
pleine bourre
je déteste ces chants balance de sens
pour les cornes
non
tout cet amour
hamon
au mcdo
ça
regardez moi
les sabots john craddock capitonné lula
4 secondes
ouais je les quatre fers en l'air
buts pour la gagner les gars au oui